it's great to be joined today by Jenny
Wilson who's a two-term Salt Lake County
Council member and Utah's Democratic
nominee for the United States Senate
seat that will be the seat
soon to be formerly held by Orrin Hatch
who is retiring Jenny is running against
Mitt Romney on the Republican side who
of course was the governor of our state
of Massachusetts at one point Jenny it's
great to talk to you let's let's jump
right into policy I mean where Utah is a
more conservative state than sort of the
average of the United States where on
policy do you see yourself as having the
the bigger disagreements with your
opponent well against Mitt Romney there
are many differences from what I can
tell but anybody who's followed Mitt
Romney knows there's been a little bit
of a migration here and there on his
issues so we'll see which Mitt Romney
were gonna get he finished out a primary
recently and won that and he's been the
nominee for a few weeks I've challenged
him to an immigration debate because we
haven't seen consistency on that but he
has stated that he is to the right of
Trump and I you know I believe in
immigration reform that we need for the
benefit of Utah and the nation to solve
this problem
I favor daca protections extending those
and clearly as a mother an elected
official just a human I'm horrified of
what's going on at our border and the
failure of this administration once it
was exposed to take care of it sure yeah
well let's dig into immigration a little
bit I mean what would be your plan in
terms of the individuals that are
already in the United States and and are
undocumented what would be your proposal
there well I think we need everyone to
have a method to step forward and have a
method to identify themselves clearly on
daca we we should move that group of
people toward citizenship others that
are here illegally and to the benefit of
our nation for the ability for us to
collect taxes for the ability of
businesses to have some certainty for
our transitory kind of related
industries like an agriculture meaning
seasonal what have you we need to
this workforce so I think having people
that have unfortunately been living in
the shadows step up I'm okay with some
form of volunteer commitment if they are
to move toward citizenship a fee if that
makes sense I'm willing to negotiate
through those but it's time we move
beyond and not to have such a break and
our norms in this nation yeah I think a
lot of people simply don't understand
the importance of these groups of folks
who have come to the United States in a
number of different industries including
agriculture including the restaurant
industry etc would anybody who does not
are there any individuals outside of
those who would meet daca requirements
that you would say are going to have to
leave well I mean clearly if we have
people who are dealing drugs and our
felons and are you know really impacting
our system in a way that doesn't benefit
it we have to do something with that
group of people we have to figure out
where and how we do that would it
whether it would be putting them behind
bars here in our nation or deporting
them I'm open to looking at those
options but I think citizens working or
people that are working toward
citizenship who would desire that who
are integrated in our communities it's
time for us to get beyond the division
on this and tackle some of these
problems on a bipartisan basis and move
forward one of the areas I'm very
interested in particularly because we've
just had at the national level major
changes made to the system of taxation
that exists both for individuals and for
corporations is to dig into that a
little bit and when your current
opponent Mitt Romney was running for
president there were some pretty
significant disagreements on tax polyMet
policy that he had with Barack Obama so
I'd like to dig into that a little bit
what is your policy on taxation do you
believe that there should be higher top
marginal rates than there currently are
on the richest Americans and if so what
would that sort of look like is that
something you're opposed to
well this is an issue I probably put
more time into than any other because I
think what we need to do is give
middle-class Utah a break middle-class
Americans a break and I was horrified
that Orrin Hatch of you as you have
mentioned is vacating the seat was not
open to negotiation and we had an up and
down vote around the holiday last year
to pass the bill I've since gone back
and issued my own modifications to that
bill which include a higher tax
corporate tax rate they also include
eliminating some of the egregious
loopholes that benefit the wealthy as
you mentioned one of them being the
carried interest tax loophole which
basically that allows those who invest
others money not to pay their fair share
so it's a complete giveaway in fact I'm
it's one of the few things that at one
point Trump and I agreed on Trump had
said we should eliminate that loophole
yet when the bill rolled around indeed
it did not so I want us to get back to
tax fairness in this nation to prevent
people who are working multiple jobs
from having an extra hit I think that we
can go back in the next Senate and in
the next Congress and negotiate through
this I mean the bill that moved forward
required or allowed corporations to keep
their tax breaks while citizens are
going to lose them down the road so if
there's some marginal benefit for a
family we're gonna lose it in eight
years so we should go back renegotiate
the cost to the deficit and the debt is
outrageous
we know the CBO has scored it almost as
high as two trillion above the one point
five we initially had heard and that's
alarming we need to get back to some
controlling the deficit in ways that
that makes sense and I just think that
Romney and I are night and day on this
issue isn't that I'm curious like isn't
the deficit thing kind of a losing
argument for the left only because we
know that it's a political football and
increasingly particularly if you know
you you look into modern monetary theory
you sort of have an understanding that
the deficit and debt in and of
themselves don't tell us whether an
economy is or isn't doing well and
aren't we sort of conceding the battle
when we even start talking about debt
and deficit other than to say there are
hypocrites on the right on this issue I
I'm scared of when progressives and
Democrats go in that direction because I
feel like it's it's engaging in a battle
we can't win well I actually maybe have
a different opinion a little on it I
worked for a congressman on the Budget
Committee in the 90s a blue Blue Dog
Democrat and I really feel that and I'm
also a local official where we balance
our budget every year the cost per
family due to higher interest rates than
the nation's paying and all of the
securities and all the investments that
we make when we hear carrying that much
debt actually hurt our ability to
deliver goods and services so I think
it's important that we do look at fine
tuning where and how our nation spends
and I can I get concerned when you you
know we have incredibly high GDP in this
nation so we can take that into account
certainly as a safety net for us but the
more and more we take on the less and
less we can do and that's why to me it's
sort of like a moral principle where we
do need to be cognizant of it and we do
know that a great economy our deficit
gets under control and we don't have
concerns but we have seen peaks and
valleys I worry about actions of this
administration and this Congress right
now including the trade war where we
could really see a quicker recession
than was anticipated so it does make
sense to me that we manage both our
deficit and our debt on a regular basis
and are cognizant of it okay yeah I mean
I think you know reasonable people can
disagree on that and I think maybe we do
going back to the taxation part where
would you set the top marginal tax rate
and and what would it be in other words
would it be 40 percent above a million
dollars a year or where would you set
that well we cut detect the corporate
tax rate down to 14 and then or sorry
the I think 21 and now I'm suggesting we
go up to 25 percent which is still a
reduction downward but it's higher than
this bill and this
new law has put into place and I think
getting some adjustment on the corporate
rate is reasonable I just think that it
went way too far at the expense of
working people and I may have been
unclear in my quote I mean when it comes
to the individual tax rate would you
raise the top tax rate and if so where
would you set it and what would be the
income threshold so I think that's
negotiable where and how because we are
seeing different levels for the very
wealthy down to those of us in great
need so I would be willing to work
through that particular issue and and
see where we can land where we actually
see a decrease or an increase of the
rate for those at the highest level and
we are giving some benefit back to
especially those working-class people
who are working day to day in and out
trying to to make it what would be the I
mean I'm just trying to understand under
so I think the numbers do sort of
indicate sort of what your philosophy is
what would be middle class what would be
the upper income limit for somebody
who's middle class who you'd be
targeting and trying to help so I think
what I what I'm really saying is that
people who are you know making forty
fifty sixty thousand dollars a year in
the state of Utah need a break and
that's the rate where I think we need to
be the most aware and pay you know and
and and give some tax relief to that
middle worker who is out there working
you know our in our on our ranches who
is working in our convenience stores
who's working you know a job where they
get up every day and do their thing and
many of them working several so that's
that's the kind of mid-level rate that
I'm looking to provide relief to all
right we have been speaking with Jenny
Wilson two terms Salt Lake County
Council member currently running against
Republican candidate for US Senate Mitt
Romney she is the Democratic nominee you
can learn more about her campaign at
Wilson for senate.com Jenny we're going
to be following it and best of luck to
you well I appreciate I appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you for a few
minutes today